six one seven eight three zero 47 50
let's see who's holding on from the nine
to five area code who's there from 9:00
to 5:00 9:00 to 5:00 I can I can hear
you but I'm down there yeah whose uh my
name is George all right George I wanted
to ask you what is your opposition to
socialism because if you want to do the
research about job requirements you see
that the average IQ for most most
careers are in the 115 and above brain
and now most people think about
automation only about manual labor but
in this day and age or started
experiencing some white-collar jobs
being automated and it's only increased
so and this will not be reversed so the
only solution
okay so no let's see if we can break
these things down into it so the first
question was what's my opposition to
socialism so that I've laid out in a
number of videos extensively I'm a
Social Democrat not a socialist then you
went into most careers require an IQ of
115 or above we're what were you getting
that data
well most most little clusters unless
you're doing something like oil
extraction or some other okay so the new
statement is most middle-class careers
so by most you mean more than 50 percent
yes and how do you define middle-class
well if you don't have this paycheck to
paycheck then you can afford to buy a
house at some point at least the
mortgage can afford to have at least two
cars that's pretty much the bare minimum
I you know okay I mean I think it
depends on where you live that that sort
of definition would vary drastically in
terms of what and all the money for
retirement as well okay I think
depending on where you live that is very
differently achievable I would you would
you submit that there are lots of people
who in much of this country can live a
middle-class lifestyle as you described
working as for example a construction
worker well very few people can do that
only people that are male healthy and
well hold on a second your your now
you're moving the goalposts because
first you said I'm not more than hold on
a second
let me see if I can just understand what
you're saying because you're saying a
lot of different things first you said
that you need to have an IQ of 115 in
order to have a middle-class job then
you said most people need that 51% or
more in many careers now you're saying
that okay the example I gave does apply
a construction worker I think you would
concede doesn't have to have an IQ of
115 but then you said well that would
only be if they are male and healthy and
you added a couple of other requirements
so I'm sensing that you don't
necessarily know exactly what argument
you're trying to make I'm saying that
very few people can do those kinds of
manual jobs that pay well and the vast
majority of the middle-class jobs are
white-collar and require levels of
intelligence that only one in three one
in seven people have yeah I just don't
agree I just don't where are you getting
that data where's that data coming from
from because this is just a superficial
that has averages for what the IQ
average for every type of bachelors is
and for the type of career and basically
for nursing you need something like
around 105 for economics and accounting
you need something like 106 to 108 same
with psychology for teaching you need
110 but those are all those are all what
you would call white collar careers and
the numbers you're citing or below 115
so that seems to directly quell the
thing the thing is though that that's
that's the 115 number that's when people
are at their peak and that's only
between age 20 and 30 the thing is that
I keep drops it's about five points per
decade so within one decade that would
basically be know that that's what
you've now given me like 12 different
sets of requirements and ifs ands and
buts like I I I would rethink this and
call back
okay I got a lot of people holding but
what you're saying is not making sense I
disagree with the premise and I just
might immediately okay let's take a
quick break don't hang up if you're
holding because we are taking more calls
so don't hang up we'll be right back
with more of your phone calls after this